GREAT DALE HAWERCHUK. FOR
SURE.
>> John G.: THE BEAUTY LEAGUE.
>> John S.: STARS ON THE OUT.
AND NOW THE CHASE IS OUT ALONG E
BOARDS BY ANDREJ SEKERA. TRIED O
STOP UP, BUT THE PUCK COMES TO
PETTERSSON BEHIND THEHE GET
UP AND DRIES OFF THE SKATE, IT T
DERMOTT.
DRIVES INTO THE CORNER FOR
ENTRY.
CANUCKS TWO ON ONE -- THWART --
PETTERSSON IN.
AND OETTINGER OBVS
DALLAS ZONE.
HEISKANEN AROUND FOR RADULOV.
A .
HERE'S VANCOUVER.
THROUGH CENTRE.
A SEKERA.
HIT A BODY IN FRONT.
REBOUND PUT TOWARDS THE GOAL.
CANUCKS HAVE IT AGAIN.
BRAD HUNT
AND TO THAT
PASS.
>> THERE YOU CAN SEE.
BROCK BOESER SPOTTED ON HEISKANN
WHO GOT IN HIS WAY ALLOWING
GOING INTO THE THIRD.
>> John S.: STARS LIFT THE SUTE.
AND THE
AND THE STARS PLAY THE PUCK TO
CENTRE.
PODKOLZIN.
VASILY PODKOLZIN SCORES!LZIN
TRAVIS DERMOTT TRYING TO SHAKE
FREE FROM HINTZ.
GETS THE PUCK IN.
MILLER TIPS IT T T MIND THAT
AS THAT ONE BY HINTZ WHISTLES
WIDE.
GET SQUARED AROUND. CROWD.